il est évident qu'on a régulièrement à
l'atelier ces petits boulots à peu près
4 à 5 par mois
cd tête fracturée cole passagers vernis
depuis 20 ans grégoire d'amico soit
nouveau guitar passionné de musique il
devient luthier en 1995 dans un sous-sol
de pavillons il crée lui même les
instruments
alors là et je vous montre enfin compte
un manche de guitare
voilà donc à la bave
on voit que c'est une une planche voilà
on réalise avec la dégonfler raboteuse
on vient faire des collages
ce qui va permettre de mettre des boîtes
différents dans le dans le manche d'un
féret des bois différents et ça permet
au mois de moins bouger avec les
problèmes d'hydrométrie et des guitares
sur mesure parfois très haut de gamme
pour des grands de la musique française
et internationale
charlelie couture francis cabrel laurent
voulzy ou encore mick jagger
alors voilà ce dont je t'avais parler
1la la corde obame est donc celle ci tu
vois là sa particularité c'est d'être
complètement en palissandre donc là tu
vas avoir un son un petit peu plus
encore pu médium voilà voilà entre les
ducs l'accord mais pas mal de médium
elle le sous sol devient très vite trop
petit tout comme l'atelier dans le
hameau de villars où à guyancourt
il déménage à buc et ouvre une boutique
et c'est surtout de faire un lieu où les
gens se sentent bien voilà se sentent à
l'aise pour essayer leurs instruments
avec une âme avec avec avec on va dire
une
un peu de charme qui soit pas un lieu
édulcorer un peu insipide
parce que souvent les magasins on va
dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas vraiment
d'imaginaire voilà et nous on a mis un
peu nos tripes
ok ben je l'aï essayée grassi voix leur
a fait une adresse qui fonctionne grâce
au bouche à oreille elle les clients
sont des fidèles
ici je vous c'est vraiment un endroit
extraordinaire il déjà il ya beaucoup de
choix de deux guitares et puis il a un
savoir faire
ce pour ce qui est de le réglage
l'occurrence c'était pour une casse
malheureusement c'est une guitare
qu'elle je tiens énormément que j'ai
depuis que je suis gamin puis j'ai 17
ans j'en ai 30 37 bientôt et je voulais
vraiment pas
voilà les vrais manques imlach fasse
plus de vingt ans de savoir-faire et 700
produits en boutique avec toujours à la
fin le petit mot de circonstance il joue
bien ça les saluts bonne musique